lastly for this question construct an
SQL statement to achieve all the flights
commencing from here on this day and
sort the data are the results on
departure time and even though the only
things you display our flight number and
departure date okay so how do we go
about this
let's stop I remember one of the full
pieces that go into an SQL query there's
four lines zero move up select what's
next from third line where last ones the
easiest one usually usually it's a
sorting it's a sorting row but it
usually says order bar which is actually
kind of like a common language English
way to say it okay all right now let's
come back to the question constructed in
school so what are we trying to do
retrieve all fights commencing from now
here's the way I'm going to go about it
I mean get me grab a screenshot
let's see well let's do it yes
okay now the reason why I put it there
is because even though the order that's
here doesn't match the order that's that
our SQL query will be if I go through
this one by one I'll make sure again
I'll check off everything that I need
and it'll be represented in my query
okay so now that I've got this all set
up kind of like my grid okay I'll read
through and I'll put in the parts that
are relevant
okay so the first piece of information
um again all flights commencing from Los
Angeles Airport okay so and they they
tell us very helpfully an airport code
and they also tell us the date that it
needs to come from okay
now this question relates to the
previous one right so you shouldn't be
making up there we go
you shouldn't be making up field names
all the field names have been provided
to you okay so if I know that it's
commencing from Los Angeles Airport okay
how am I going to say that and where am
I going to put that in first question
okay
add these four rows where is this piece
of information in a slot in
where it's a condition right it's the
thing that I need all my records to me
otherwise I'm not interested in okay so
it's where it's up here right now LAX
which field is I can refer to which team
what does it come from all flights
commencing from from LAX right so you
come back you have a look here okay now
when you think about it you know that
it's going to be related to either
airports or flights it's got to be one
of those right all the other ones don't
have anything to do with a location okay
like Los Angeles okay is it going to be
airport code or start airport code which
one makes more sense of the data answer
start airport code okay
cuz I'm not interested in the airports
themselves I'm interested in flights
okay
so I'm gonna say start airport code well
I should say flights thought it started
and they give me a code okay so okay all
right now I'm gonna run out of time but
hopefully space sorry but you'll you'll
have plenty of space to do this this is
not the only condition I have to meet
right right after this it says on 23rd
of August 2012 okay so how do I write
that first thing is I think I've heard
it somewhere I'm gonna need an end right
because that's the logical sort of
operate of it I need to satisfy both of
these at the same time now what field
what field come back to this diagram
yeah it's right there it's all love
together okay so okay now this is kind
of a tricky bit it's a bit ambiguous for
you guys because it's like what format
is this in I didn't mean to give you a
format
I was lenient and if you said 23rd
August 2012 I let that fly okay however
of all the formats that you would get a
date in if you're putting into SQL you
would never put it in this format can
anyone tell me why
why why would 23 space honest space 2012
be a bad way to input data into an SQL
crew yeah oh it's so redundant it's like
redundant and a half it's it's so many
characters right where we could just
substitute single numbers for things
like this in 2012 it's like well even if
you're going to be going across
different centuries you could still put
that in a more succinct way than using
four characters for okay four bytes for
that ripoff okay so you know I I
accepted it anyway because I didn't
specify but a nice way to say we've just
been 23 well you could have put it if
you were really really super ultra
special you could have put it in just as
a just as an integer and calculated the
number of days I didn't expect it okay
duck where there's my condition now what
else do I have to fill in yeah I've got
in the question the results to be sorted
on departure time okay so that's going
to be order by right so now where am I
going to go which which table which
field
departure time yeah see it's kind of a
um it's kind of a red herring wasn't it
it was it was spoken it was written in a
very very normal language way sorted by
the patch of time but it was messing
with you because there's no fuel called
the part of time the closest thing we
have to departure tonight is that date
time which we've already been talking
about okay ascending or descending
ascending or descending
ascending or descending ascending why
not because it doesn't matter okay
Christian doesn't say it just says
should be sorted on that okay so the
important thing that was just that you
got the right field okay just messing
with you okay now I there is also a sort
of under par to tie so I've accounted
for that now only the flight number and
departure date such time should be
displayed okay so where does that go the
the things that are displayed these two
things where where do they go select
they're right at the top okay so how
we're gonna write this flight number so
that's again from flights what is it
called
flight number the flight ID
and departure date which is the same
thing okay last bit which is kind of
hopefully if you've been doing this
question and paying attention it's
really easy from just means where you
getting all this data from flights now
for this reason
once you've finished this the particular
kind of question that I gave you all of
this data comes from the one table okay
so it would have been alright if you'd
said flights and omitted all of the
flights thought this flights not that
buckle up because it's unambiguous all
of this data comes from one place anyway
okay however I still think it's good
idea I didn't deduct any marks for it
but in the future it's quite common to
get questions like this and you're going
to be in from you know you pull the data
from more than one table okay so when
you've got something like flight number
or start day time etc okay that could
come from a whole variety of different
tables so you'll need to specify which
ones so you won't be able to get away
with just saying that you'll have to say
flights dot etc and there is your
terrible messy SQL creep that's it okay
any questions